in the place known as the town that
never forgets a monument to memories
this is sanctuary a place to remember
the loved ones lost during the pandemic
and when it's burned to the ground next
week hopefully a place of catharsis and
we all lost people we were all isolated
we all felt really kind of at odds and
somehow contributing to something so
beautiful and then watching it go
together is a kind of marvelous idea i
think
james and anita have traveled miles to
come here to remember and say goodbye to
tony rice a keen artist who died in the
early days of the pandemic and who is
now part of a piece of art himself we
thought this was a great way to mark
this occasion because we couldn't even
go to the funeral and support his video
and his good friend he's a bit like an
adoptive grandad to us so he always uh
loved art
so
we've come a long way to come here and
just wanted to
to have him be part of this it's amazing
sanctuary hasn't been without its
detractors the project has cost 650 000
pounds most of it raised via donations
but 70 has gone back into the local
community and it's a community that
seems to understand its purpose
we've had relatives pass with it so
this is what we're doing we're putting
our little
thing to it i think it's brilliant yeah
we've left a couple of messages he's
done some stuff for his granddad to say
missy grandad did a picture with his
family and all that it's good to come
together and just
realize that we were never really alone
during that period
even if it did feel like it it's
beautiful
it's an emotional project too for the
artists who built it you look around and
you see someone writing i miss you
grandpa or i miss your mom or my loving
daughter i mean look
when that happens
you know i'm i'm satisfied sanctuary
will be put to the torch after just
seven days the thousands of thoughts and
memories it contains will last much
longer than that
fraser moored sky news bedwar